six heures s'ils osent se réveille
entouré des montagnes les plus
vertigineuses de l'île ce cirque qu'on
ne quitte pas est intimement lié au
thermalisme
les eaux s'infiltre dans les montagnes
s'enrichissent et rejaillissent en eau
minérale naturelle
une richesse naturelle exploité depuis
le 19e siècle l'homme et la nature
c'est ça la vie des agents du
département gestionnaire de
l'établissement thermal de cilaos
à l'heure où il fait encore frais
l'équipe de la cellule technique et
entretient pensons poste a aussi à la
bulle et saison à l'ouverture notre rôle
à nous c'est de vérifier
s'il n'y a pas d'anomalie qui traînent
on vérifie le niveau des cuves
on vérifie à l'allumage et fonctionnel
fonctionne bien c'est l'élément
essentiel qui va préparer cette journée
donc il faut que tout soit impeccable
on n'a pas droit à l'erreur d'un vieux
paramédical il doit rester propre jeu
puis au jeu tous les points d'accès aux
bains douches les terrains après 28 ans
de services au terme
patrick payet que des le site de cet
internat sur le podium
d'ouvrir tout vérifié patrick réveille
chaque jour ce lieu avec le bruit de
l'eau comme c'est de l'eau thermale
s'est durcie dépôt de rouille pas dire
qu'elle soit sale c'est une autre usine
neuve et on va stocker on va faire
circuler dans les cuves de stockage
le surplus ce va repartir dans la
rivière ça va tourner en permanence
toute la journée et une serre une partie
de l'eau va être utilisé pour les soins
on est dans un cadre où c'est magnifique
on à la nature autour de nous là on est
à la lisière de la forêt après après on
a tout de la forêt jusqu'au piton des
neiges la journée juste au pied du piton
des neiges
et c'est quand même magnifique mois
quand j'ouvre le matin je regarde le
grand ménage
c'est quelque chose qui nous fait du
bien
pendant ce temps bien plus bas un autre
technicien est aux aguets à la source
des trois sources
un périmètre protégé autour des sources
pour pas qu'ils aient de l'infiltration
de problèmes au niveau de la source on
est obligé de faire un périmètre de
protection
on peut à la fois être un jour amenés à
entretenir l'espace vert le lendemain il
ya un souci sur un matériel on doit
aller voir aussi à des problèmes
électriques ont à intervenir au niveau
des sources
il faut avoir tout le suivi sanitaire
aussi
on a aussi la responsabilité de
l'ouverture la fermeture du bâtiment
donc au public
on est donc là haut niveau journée au
niveau des sources
donc on a les trois sources la 106
rennais la sandero la sauce
madness ça c'est des dom étanche pour à
la fois protéger la source pour pâti de
problèmes matériaux de bactéries qu'ils
puissent y accéder est il sincère aussi
justement à récupérer au niveau des
coupoles le gaz co2 qui est dégagé pour
leur est envoyé au niveau de l' usine
d'embouteillage moelleux de travailler
sur un site comme ça on peut en plein
coeur de cilaos
c'est formidable donc on se dit pas tous
les matins
ah non j'ai pas envie d'aller travailler
non non non nous on vient et on est
heureux de venir travailler
donc c'est ça qui est ça que j'aime des
eaux thermales qui viennent du coeur de
ces montagnes et qui remontent le long
de ses tuyaux
tout doit être parfait pour les curistes
et les touristes
les agents d'accueil sont spécialisés
dans ce premier contact ce premier
sourire ça va ça c'est pour le médecin
pas d'aller ça c'est le volet trois mois
c'est le contact val contact avec la
clientèle moi je ne ferais pas entouré
enfin dans un bureau à fond derrière un
ordinateur doit c'est le seul contact
qui ont-elles tous les jours la
rencontre de deux de plein de gens à
nouveau tout le temps quoi c'est
principalement les remettre en confiance
et mettre à l'aise car bien que tout va
bien se dérouler au hall d'accueil qui a
bien changé au fil des années un lieu
revivifiant qui mérite à mieux être
connu
les curistes entre alors dans la partie
de soins pour commencer avec un sourire
un accueil assez chaleureuse comme ça
ici on les met en confiance déjà c'est
les premiers soins qu on prodigue
voilà pour eux c'est important d'avoir
et puis le fait de les avoir chaque
année de les revoir de nous revoir ça
crée des liens
et c'est la première réalisation
adam g
une cure est une prestation médicale
encadrée par des infirmières du
département c'est de l'accueil d'un
public en demandant besoin de 7 à 99 ans
voilà et qui dès qu'ils demandent un
soulagement
un soulagement en complément du
traitement médical etc ce que les
médecins ont prescrit et que j'ai
retranscrit ici vous la donner aux
agents de soins qui sont dans le couloir
or dans notre équipe on est deux
infirmières avec deux volets bien
différent de fonction ma collègue
s'occupe plus particulièrement des
affections métaboliques notamment du
diabète de type 2 non insulinodépendant
est également de la mise en place
d'ateliers éducatifs concernant
l'arthrose
les habitudes de vie
l'hygiène de vie l'alimentation et un
atelier où elle nous apprend à se
relaxer d'une personne à une autre
c'est là ressenti différent parce que
y'en a qui aiment bien les tonifiante
dans la came bien et relaxante donc là
deux colonnes et la beauté pure l'accent
que la douche à jets il a une approche
on va dire c'est très convivial quoi on
a des affinités après avec sata curistes
y en a qui sont vraiment malheureux de
repartir au bout de trois semaines
la dcri ce qui qui pleure
les curistes défilent jusqu'à 60
personnes par matinée et tous sont aux
petits soins
au fil de la journée
c'est du personnel motivé que nous avons
rencontrés
faire du bien aux autres seraient
peut-être leur secret